Générique
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous.
Heureux de vous retrouver pour
"Parlement hebdo".
Nous allons revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Nous sommes avec
Thomas Ménagé.
Vous êtes député Rassemblement
National du Loiret depuis 2022.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va faire
le bilan de l'action de
l'Assemblée nationale un an après
les élections législatives qui
n'ont donné qu'une majorité
relative à Emmanuel Macron.
La dissolution du mouvement
écologiste les Soulèvements de la
Terre a été prononcée en Conseil
des ministres.
Gérald Darmanin dénonce les
violences des militants, mais la
dissolution divise les
parlementaires.
Le Sénat a adopté un projet de loi
qui valorise les
filières
industrielles qui s'engagent
dans la transition écologique.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a un an, les
Français ont élu leurs nouveaux
députés.
Un an et une réforme des retraites
plus tard, le gouvernement
parvient à faire passer une bonne
partie de ses textes, avec ou sans
49.3, mais à quel prix?
Voici le menu parlementaire.
- Au programme des prochaines
semaines, le partage de la valeur,
avec la transposition de l'accord
signé par la quasi-totalité des
partenaires sociaux.
Les dispositifs comme
l'intéressement ou la
participation seront étendus aux
entreprises entre 11 et 49
salariés.
En séance, le projet de loi
d'orientation du ministère de la
Justice.
Sur la période 2023-2027, près de
10.000 postes seront créés,
notamment des magistrats et des
greffiers.
Le garde des Sceaux promet de
diviser par 2 le délai de
traitement en 4 ans.
Les parlementaires vont ensuite se
pencher sur l'industrie verte.
Réindustrialisation et
décarbonation sont au programme.
Avant la pause estivale, les
députés examineront le projet de
loi Plein emploi.
Objectif: 5% de chômage en 2027.
Les allocataires du RSA se verront
demander des contreparties.
- Kathia Gilder: Il reste des
textes à l'ordre du jour à
l'Assemblée.
Les députés RN pourraient-ils
voter le projet de loi Plein
emploi qui conditionne le RSA à
des contreparties?
- Thomas Ménagé: On peut voter des
textes avec la majorité, quand ça
va dans le bon sens.
Sur ce texte, nous sommes en
désaccord profond.
Changer le nom de Pôle emploi en
France Travail, ça ne va rien
changer.
On s'inquiète d'une sorte de
concurrence entre les gens au RSA
et les gens au SMIC.
Cela va créer des "bullshit jobs".
Cela va uberiser la société.
Cela va faire en sorte que les
employeurs vont envoyer des gens
au RSA.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est une réforme
libérale?
- Thomas Ménagé: Tout à fait.
On va créer des emplois qui ne
vont pas permettre aux gens de
vivre décemment.
Il y a peut-être des abus sur le
RSA.
Il faut absolument attaquer la
fraude.
Il faut aussi améliorer nos
dispositifs de contrôle.
2 milliards d'euros de RSA sont
mal distribués.
Il y a des choses à faire,
mais pas cette obligation d'heures.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le projet de
loi Plein emploi, ce sera non?
- Thomas Ménagé:
Vraisemblablement.
Nous verrons au moment des débats.
Il peut y avoir des amendements et
des évolutions.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous vous
présentez comme constructifs.
Si des choses sont bonnes, vous
pouvez les voter?
- Thomas Ménagé: Bien sûr.
Le texte sur le partage de la
valeur, par exemple, il va dans
le sens de notre politique
sur l'intéressement, la
participation, l'association des
salariés à la réussite de
l'entreprise.
On ne veut pas opposer le patron
et les salariés.
Cela va dans le bon sens.
Ca ne règle pas tous les
problèmes.
Il reste la question du salaire.
Il faut traiter cela.
Mais cela va beaucoup plus dans le
bon sens.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'il y a
des textes qui peuvent recevoir
votre soutien après la réforme des
retraites?
- Thomas Ménagé: Ce n'est pas
parce que le gouvernement est
passé en force tant par
l'utilisation du 49.3 que par le
blocage de l'initiative
parlementaire qu'on ne va pas
essayer d'améliorer les textes qui
vont dans le bon sens.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
vous pensez que le gouvernement
d'Elisabeth Borne a un avenir à
partir de la mi-juillet?
- Thomas Ménagé:
Vraisemblablement, le contrat
n'est pas rempli.
Le contrat était de rétablir la
confiance avec les Français.
Il suffit de sortir du
Palais-Bourbon ou du Sénat pour se
rendre compte que les Français
n'ont pas du tout confiance en ce
gouvernement ou en Elisabeth
Borne.
Je ne suis pas là pour faire des
pronostics, mais elle n'a pas
rempli le contrat.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'il y
aura un avant et un après réforme
des retraites?
- Thomas Ménagé: Il y a une
blessure profonde qui s'est créée.
Il y a un fossé entre la classe
politique et les Français.
Il s'est encore creusé.
Surtout vis-à-vis de la majorité
et de la maccronie.
On ne peut pas
faire comme si rien
ne s'était passé.
Nous, on a une ligne de conduite
qui est l'intérêt général.
On ne fait pas d'opposition de
principe, quand bien même le
comportement a été indigne de la
part du gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cela fait un
an que cette majorité relative a
été élue.
68 textes ont été adoptés.
Cela veut dire que cette Assemblée
fonctionne?
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous l'avons
toujours dit.
Nous proposions la proportionnelle
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Cela peut montrer que ça peut
marcher.
Il y a une Assemblée nationale
représentative,
presque parce qu'on est
en sous-effectif
par rapport à ce qu'on représente
dans la société, et les
textes passent.
Cela peut se faire, car nous avons
une position pragmatique et non
sectaire.
LFI bloque tout et ne veut rien
faire passer quand bien même ça va
dans le bon sens, ça ne peut pas
avancer.
Mais avec nous, si.
- Alexandre Poussart: Lorsqu'on
vous écoute, on a l'impression que
vous êtes là pour aider le
gouvernement à faire passer
certains textes.
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous ne sommes
pas là pour les aider, nous sommes
là pour les Français.
Pendant la réforme des retraites,
on n'a
pas épargné le gouvernement.
Il y aura des débats qui seront
très vifs pour la loi
comme sur le RSA.
On peut avoir des discussions très
fermes d'opposition mais on ne
bloque pas ce qui peut améliorer
le quotidien des Français.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous êtes un
peu comme le groupe LR.
Vous vous dites d'opposition mais
vous faites passer certains
textes.
- Thomas Ménagé: Non, parce qu'on
ne va pas négocier et être en
soutien à chaque fois.
On s'est opposés à la plupart des
textes.
On n'a pas voté une majorité de
On reste dans l'opposition.
Nous ne sommes pas là pour faire
du buzz, pour faire le bazar.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes 88
députés, le premier groupe en tant
que tel.
Néanmoins, il n'y a aucun
texte du
Rassemblement National qui passe
depuis le début de la législature,
et peu d'amendements.
Le gouvernement dit qu'il n'a pas
besoin du vote des députés du
Rassemblement National pour faire
passer leurs textes, puisque
certaines voix, principalement des
LR, suffisent.
- Thomas Ménagé: Sur certains
textes, c'est le cas.
Sur d'autres, on a été la force
décisive qui a fait basculer d'un
côté ou d'un autre le passage des
amendements.
Quand nous votons avec la gauche,
la macronie accuse les
accointances entre le RN et la
gauche, et quand c'est l'inverse,
on nous accuse aussi.
Chacun se renvoie la balle.
On voit qu'on a quand même, du
fait de notre présence, comme par
exemple sur l'immigration, une
victoire des idées.
Nous influençons les textes et la
ligne actuelle du gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder: Cette semaine,
Gérald Darmanin a décidé la
dissolution du mouvement les
Soulèvements de la Terre.
Il les accuse de cautionner les
violences à Sainte-Soline ou
contre le projet d'autoroute
Lyon-Turin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Aucune cause ne
justifie que l'on blesse des
policiers ou des gendarmes.
Deux jours d'affrontements, une
autoroute occupée, une voie ferrée
coupée et de nombreux personnels
des services publics qui sont
devant la haine et la violence.
A la demande du président de la
République et de la Première
ministre, demain matin, je
présenterai au Conseil des
ministres le décret de dissolution
des Soulèvements de la Terre.
- Kathia Gilder: Depuis, le décret
de dissolution est effectif.
Est-ce que cette dissolution est,
pour vous, justifiée?
Est-ce que les Soulèvements de la
Terre constituaient une menace
réelle pour l'ordre public?
- Thomas Ménagé: Je le pense.
Il suffit de voir leur
comportement.
Ils ont agressé le maire de
Toulouse, il y a quelques jours.
Il faut avoir une ligne claire
vis-à-vis des groupuscules.
Nous, dès décembre 2022, nous
avions demandé la dissolution de
tous les groupuscules violents,
peu importe leur bord.
C'est de l'écoterrorisme, de
l'agribashing.
C'est très dangereux pour les élus
ruraux, comme je le suis.
Je défends nos agriculteurs.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la
première fois qu'un mouvement
écologiste est dissous par l'Etat.
- Thomas Ménagé: N'importe qui
peut s'exprimer et exprimer son
rejet de la politique du
gouvernement en matière
environnementale.
Ca se fait dans le respect de
l'Etat de droit et de nos
institutions.
Ca ne se fait pas avec violence.
On voit qu'il y a une montée en
puissance alimentée par les élus
de la République, dont certains
vont avec leur écharpe soutenir
ces personnes qui, parfois, ont
été touchées par une interdiction
de manifester.
C'est ça, qui est inquiétant.
Si demain il y avait La France
Insoumise au pouvoir, je pense
qu'il n'y aurait plus d'Etat de
droit.
On ne respecterait plus aucune
règle.
- Kathia Gilder: Cela vous choque
que des élus de la République
puissent se retrouver dans des
manifestations, alors qu'ils ont
le droit d'y assister?
- Thomas Ménagé: Si la
manifestation est pacifique, et
autorisée, oui.
Si elle est interdite, non.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce n'est pas la
place d'un élu de la République,
une manifestation?
- Thomas Ménagé: Bien sûr que si.
Le plus important, cependant,
c'est d'être là pour travailler et
faire notre travail de
parlementaire.
Après, si la manifestation est
interdite...
Si ceux qui votent les lois ne les
respectent pas, où va-t-on?
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous parlez
d'écoterrorisme pour les
Soulèvements de la Terre?
- Thomas Ménagé: Oui, c'est une
sorte de terrorisme des
écologistes.
Tous ceux qui vont attaquer les
exploitations, les
infrastructures, c'est une forme
de terrorisme.
- Kathia Gilder: Les avocats du
mouvement disent que le mouvement
n'est pas en lui-même violent et
ne dégrade pas des biens.
Est-ce qu'il ne fallait pas plutôt
condamner les personnes
responsables des violences plutôt
que dissoudre le mouvement?
- Thomas Ménagé: A ma
connaissance, les Soulèvements de
la Terre n'ont pas dénoncé les
violences, n'ont pas exclu ces
personnes.
Ils n'ont pas fait preuve d'une
volonté de pacifier leur combat,
qui est noble.
Ils ont toujours accompagné ces
éléments violents qui font partie.
L'ensemble des interventions des
Soulèvements de la Terre est
émaillé de violence.
Le ministre n'a pas pris cette
décision sur la base d'intentions.
Il y a des faits.
On ne peut que soutenir cette
décision.
Il faut protéger ceux qui bossent,
nos agriculteurs, qui sont
attaqués par l'association.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dans
certaines manifestations
d'agriculteurs, il y a parfois des
dégradations, des policiers
blessés.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un deux
poids, deux mesures?
- Thomas Ménagé: Dans toute
manifestation, il peut y avoir des
débordements, mais ici, c'est
organisé, voulu et répété
à chaque
fois avec ce groupe.
Dans chaque manifestation, que ce
soit des agriculteurs, des
manifestations sociales, il peut y
avoir des violences.
Mais à aucun moment ces violences
ne sont tolérées.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
comprenez cette révolte contre
l'inaction climatique du
gouvernement, qui a d'ailleurs été
condamné?
- Thomas Ménagé: Je peux
comprendre que les jeunes
s'inquiètent.
Je peux comprendre l'inquiétude
vis-à-vis des changements
climatiques.
Mais ça se changera par les urnes,
par les politiques publiques.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'on va
détruire l'outil de travail d'une
personne qu'on va faire changer
les choses.
Je ne crois pas que la violence
permette de faire changer les
choses dans notre pays.
Je crois en la démocratie.
Ces jeunes peuvent s'engager dans
des partis politiques.
Ils peuvent venir nous accompagner
pour évoluer, pour proposer des
politiques publiques ambitieuses
en matière environnementale.
Mais il faut le faire avec le
respect de ceux qui travaillent.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va
continuer à parler écologie.
Cette semaine, le Sénat a adopté
le projet de loi Industrie verte,
qui va favoriser les filières
industrielles qui s'engagent dans
la transition écologique.
Il n'est pas toujours facile de
concilier industrie et protection
de l'environnement.
- Il faut réindustrialiser la
France et décarboner l'économie.
C'est le projet de la loi
Industrie verte adopté par le
Sénat.
Les nouvelles usines qui vont
s'implanter vont être soumises à
des procédures moins complexes.
- Bruno Le Maire: Nous voulons
réduire par 2 les délais
d'ouverture d'usines,
de 17 mois à 9 mois.
- Les fonds d'un nouveau produit
d'épargne pourra être placé dès la
naissance et bloqué jusqu'à la
majorité.
Le gouvernement espère mobiliser 1
milliard d'euros de collecte pour
financer la transition écologique.
Une fausse bonne idée, pour les
sénateurs de gauche, qui proposent
un ISF climatique.
- Face à l'endettement de notre
pays, on ne peut se priver de
taxer ceux qui ont le mode de vie
qui pollue le plus.
- Les communes vont également
pouvoir acquérir les terrains qui
ne sont plus entretenus pour
installer de nouvelles usines.
- Beaucoup d'intercommunalités
déclarent avoir refusé des projets
d'implantation économique par
manque de foncier.
Pour réindustrialiser la France,
16.000 à 20.000 hectares seront
nécessaires.
La moitié pourrait se faire en
recyclage de friches.
L'autre moitié, en
artificialisation nouvelle.
- Pour lutter contre la rareté des
terrains constructibles, imposée
par la loi zéro artificialisation
nette, les sénateurs ont décidé
d'exclure les terrains industriels
du quota d'artificialisation
des sols.
Le projet de loi sera au programme
de l'Assemblée
la deuxième
semaine de juillet.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
le groupe RN va voter ce texte
Industrie verte à l'Assemblée?
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous allons voir
les débats.
Il y a un certain nombre de
problématiques dans ce texte.
On a déposé des amendements.
Je suis sur un territoire où le
chômage est de plus de 10%.
Je vois des usines qui ferment,
notamment dans le Gâtinais.
Développer une industrie, le
Rassemblement National est en
pointe depuis des années
là-dessus.
On n'a pas attendu le Covid et la
guerre en Ukraine pour voir qu'il
fallait arrêter les importations
et gagner en indépendance.
Il y aura des amendements pour
aider les petites communes à
s'industrialiser.
Si on exclut au niveau du zéro
artificialisation nette or
l'industrie, il faudra le faire
pour l'emploi aussi.
J'ai quelques petites usines qui
s'implantent, notamment vers
Château-Renard et Courtenay, et il
n'y a pas de logements.
Si on ne peut pas loger les
personnes qui vont travailler, il
y a un problème.
- Kathia Gilder: 90.000 emplois
industriels ont été créés.
Vous reconnaissez qu'Emmanuel
Macron a fait du bon travail pour
faire revenir des usines en
France?
- Thomas Ménagé: Il y a eu une
augmentation des investissements,
mais je constate qu'il y a eu des
créations et aussi énormément de
suppressions.
Toutes les usines qui se créent,
tous les projets qu'il peut y
avoir actuellement, notamment
l'arrivée d'usines comme Tesla, on
ne peut y être que favorables.
Il y a des enjeux sociaux,
économiques, d'emploi, des enjeux
environnementaux.
Il faut éviter que tout cela ne
soit fait à l'autre bout du monde
dans des conditions qui ne
respectent pas les droits du
travail, comme on le fait en France.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cela
n'aurait peut-être pas été
possible il y a 10 ans.
Est-ce que des choses ont été
faites?
- Thomas Ménagé: Il y a eu un
changement de paradigme,
malheureusement beaucoup trop
tardif.
La plupart des gouvernements
successifs ont fait tout l'inverse
depuis des années.
Le Covid a permis de faire évoluer
les mentalités.
On aurait aimé que ce soit le cas
plus tôt.
J'espère que cette usine Tesla et
Elon Musk investiront dans notre
pays.
Ce sont des emplois à la clé.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce qui fait débat
aussi, c'est l'objectif zéro
artificialisation nette des sols
en 2050, comme fixé par la loi sur
le climat votée l'an dernier.
Est-ce que cet objectif est
viable?
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous avons déposé
dans le cadre de ce texte des
amendements pour en exclure les
petites communes.
Elles se retrouvent en difficulté.
Il faut adapter cet objectif.
Il y a des fermetures d'écoles.
Si on ne peut pas créer des
logements, on ne peut pas
installer de nouvelles usines.
Si on se dit zéro
artificialisation nette en France
mais que de l'autre bout du monde,
on fait de la déforestation, on
fait des usines beaucoup moins
vertueuses que les nôtres, il y a
une contradiction.
Si on veut réindustrialiser,
relocaliser, c'est bien.
Mais si l'Assemblée nationale vote
une résolution pour dire stop,
c'est un paradoxe.
- Alexandre Poussart: Bruno Le
Maire annonce qu'il veut favoriser
les voitures électriques produites
en France et en Europe face aux
voitures chinoises.
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous appelons ce
protectionnisme de nouveau depuis
des dizaines d'années.
J'attends de voir dans les faits.
On a souvent été déçus.
C'est une victoire idéologique.
On se rend compte qu'on avait
raison avant beaucoup.
Tant mieux si certains ouvrent les
yeux aujourd'hui.
On les accompagnera et on ne
pourra que les soutenir.
- Kathia Gilder: Emmanuel Macron
vante une ISF climatique.
Bonne idée?
- Thomas Ménagé: Après avoir
supprimé l'ISF...
Nous allons voir ce qu'il entend
par cet ISF climatique.
Nous, nous proposons un impôt sur
la fortune financière.
Nous voulons taxer la spéculation,
mais ne pas taxer ceux qui
investissent en France et dans
l'économie réelle.
Sur le papier, cela peut être
intelligent de se dire que
l'argent des plus riches que
participer à lutter contre le
changement climatique.
- Kathia Gilder: On se quitte avec
un coup d'oeil à l'agenda du
Parlement.
Lundi, les députés entament en
séance publique l'examen du projet
de loi sur le partage de la
valeur.
C'est la traduction législative de
l'accord conclu entre les
partenaires sociaux pour favoriser
l'intéressement et la
participation.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi, les
sénateurs commencent l'examen du
projet de loi de préparation
militaire.
Il prévoit une hausse de budget
historique pour nos armées.
413 milliards d'euros sur la
période 2024-2030.
Il y aura aussi un rapport
présenté sur la santé des femmes
au travail.
On va finir sur la loi de
programmation militaire.
Vous l'avez votée à l'Assemblée.
Vous saluez donc la politique
militaire d'Emmanuel Macron?
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous saluons les
hausses de crédit que nous avions
demandées pendant la
présidentielle.
Marine Le Pen les avait défendues.
Après, il faudra faire en sorte de
maintenir notre industrie
militaire, de veiller à ce que nos
munitions viennent d'Europe et de
France.
Il y aura un certain nombre de
points sur lesquels nous serons
vigilants.
Après, c'est une programmation.
Il faut voir si c'est converti
réellement dans les projets de loi
de finances.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
souhaitez que la France reste dans
le commandement militaire intégré
de l'OTAN?
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous souhaitons
rester dans l'OTAN mais nous
souhaitons plus être dans le
commandement intégré, qui oblige
la France, quand bien même elle
déciderait l'inverse, de
participer à l'ensemble des
interventions internationales
décidées par l'OTAN.
Nous voulons que le peuple
français, via ses représentants,
ne soit pas obligé de suivre la
ligne de l'OTAN, qui est souvent
celle des Américains.
Nous avons une vision
d'indépendance.
Nous voulons être souverains pour
intervenir en coopération avec
d'autres pays, quand il le faut.
Nous ne voulons pas être liés
automatiquement.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a aussi
dans les débats à l'Assemblée
nationale sur cette loi de
programmation militaire, des
discussions sur la dissuasion
nucléaire.
Un nouveau porte-avions devrait
être créé.
Il faut renforcer les
investissements dans la dissuasion
nucléaire?
- Thomas Ménagé: Je vous aurais
répondu oui il y a quelques
années, mais encore plus
aujourd'hui.
On rêve tous d'un monde sans
conflit mais nous en avons un à
nos portes, en Ukraine.
Le monde n'est pas aussi pacifique
qu'on le souhaiterait.
Le rôle des dirigeants politiques
est de préparer la guerre pour
avoir la paix.
Nous voulons éviter la
guerre mais aussi
s'y préparer si
cela devait arriver.
- Kathia Gilder: La guerre en
Ukraine peut-elle se résoudre avec
les armes?
- Thomas Ménagé: Nous appelons de
nos voeux des négociations.
Nous avons soutenu le président de
la République quand il voulait
maintenir le dialogue avec
Vladimir Poutine tout en
condamnant cette guerre, qu'il
mène en Ukraine.
Nous appelons de nos voeux une
conférence internationale pour la
paix afin de réunir les grandes
puissances, les Ukrainiens et les
Russes.
Il n'y aura qu'une seule solution:
celle de la diplomatie
et de la paix.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci.
C'est la fin de l'émission.
Merci d'être venu.
Merci à tous de nous avoir suivis.
- Kathia Gilder: A la semaine
prochaine. Ciao.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA